it's a race and they're winning the
green omnibuses are omnipresent and
they're chasing down their few remaining
competitors you can join and keen on CLO
crafty we hardly have a chance yeah this
is a financially strong competitor that
is pushing one company after the other
out of the way hum via or collect the
cartons inside Yahoo is an impulse mark
in the bus industry where the clay that
people immediately think of and the one
which offers a wide network but there's
still huge competition from other
transport carriers we're still operating
within a competitive market so for us
there's no question about whether we
have a monopoly all those was at Hanover
bus station most of the buses are green
flix bus controls around ninety percent
of the market and it determines ticket
prices like the trip from Hanover to
Hamburg 150 kilometers 408 euros this is
it's a top you can't top that I reckon
so it's incredibly cheap my small diesel
wouldn't do it for that Luke this would
expose the only operator here uh MIT
Laval alladia unfortunately yes there
used to be a few others but I think they
may have been taken over by flex bus
which is a bit of a shame because ticket
prices have gone up dollars tyaga one is
under it so yeah yeah
it's intolerable because there's a
market leader Barrichello calm dude it's
like say so yes the prices have gone up
a bit in the last few years it's a
textbook case attack the competition by
offering dumping prices then take them
over and raise the prices again a
business style that requires nerves to
be able to hold out for the long haul
yam business interest angle we took on
angel investors from related sectors
technology investors and venture
capitalists including Holtz brink which
invests a lot in Germany and Daimler -
and now we also have larger funds
investing through their European offices
misty written and flexpays has only been
around for a few years at the company
headquarters in Munich hardly anyone is
over 30 the employees mainly take care
of the apps which customers use to buy
their tickets things are very different
at Hanover bus station meléndez Sakura
sells tickets personally to customers at
the counter his employer is one of
Germany's last independent intercity
coach companies deutsche touring was
founded over 70 years ago
in the 1950s the buses took Germans to
the Mediterranean but that's ancient
history now the company is fighting for
survival
we forego we try to convey to our
passengers that we still exist while
we're still on the road we bite the
fahren he's optimistic and he has to be
because the lawyers are coming who can
save the company 120 employees currently
fear for their jobs
Enzo Vincent August in the operation a
company file for insolvency at the end
of April so now we have just three
months to develop a continuation plan
and to come to an agreement with a
potential investor Clancy has inning
started are you already in talks as of
year we do have a history of taking over
the companies and we wouldn't rule that
out in future there are several in
Europe for example patient mark I [ __ ]
as a boss tooling the Sun you're not
interested in taking over to watch it
Erick fun and Tesla I'm not right now
after all Germany is already effectively
flicks bus country now it's Europe's
turn the shopping tour has already
started before long the grain buses may
dominate the entire European market